hey guys it's Theodore from practical
psychology and today we're going to be
doing an animated book review of the
4-hour workweek for believe nation the
4-hour workweek is written by Timothy
Ferriss now Tim is an awesome guy who
loves getting more results from less
input and he is known for all of his
awesome life hacks imagine running a
business outsourcing your life and
creating a full-time income for only
four hours a week of work while
traveling to exotic places to scuba dive
tango dance and practice MMA Fighting's
this is very possible Tim did it and he
gives us tips in this book so we can
learn how to do it too the first thing
that resonated with me was that Tim says
that most people choose unhappiness over
uncertainty many people would rather
work a nine-to-five job they hate than
have an unreliable paycheck if you're an
entrepreneur you cannot breathe doing
this he also says that many people have
very low goals and because of that they
fail you see when someone sets a really
high goal there is less competition and
you're instantly more likely to win
there are only two things that can
happen wherever you set a high goal
either you succeed or you learn and with
this kind of mentality you will win
basically Tim is telling you this
because most people can find 2 to 4
extra hours in their day to either start
or grow a simple business money machine
that can send them on these awesome
exotic resorts and getaways they put in
the extra work and truly believe that
it's possible most people aren't looking
for a million-dollar house or a Ferrari
or even a free trip to the Bahamas
instead what they're looking for is to
cure their boredom that's where the
4-hour workweek is all about giving you
the freedom to stimulate your mind and
love living your life for me learning is
my drive and offering book reviews like
this on my channel is just a way I can
make a living out of it and make an
impact on people let's talk about
something really important Tim advises
going on the low information diet he
says most of the information we gather
throughout the day falls in four
categories time consuming negative
relevant to your goals or outside of
your influence
watching soap box operas time-consuming
watching the news late at night about a
guy who has stabbed 47 times last month
negative listening to the radio about
bombings in a country halfway across the
globe outside of your influence and also
negative read about that new deadly
virus vaccine irrelevant to your goals
in fact he challenges you to find one
out of 10 things that you watch hear or
read throughout the day that aren't one
of these remove stuff like this from
your life and you'll quickly be on the
right path tim says another big concept
that Tim talks about is automation and
outsourcing I remember when I was
growing up my dad had a friend who had
spent three hours a week trimming and
mowing his yard he was a lawyer mind you
so he could easily earn a hundred
dollars an hour if he worked overtime it
would be so easy for him to hire a high
school student to do the same task for
30 dollars and if he did this he could
work overtime and make a profit of 270
dollars with this time now this is
different if you enjoy doing stuff like
this and if there is value to you of
doing it but he is always complaining
about how you have to dig up weeds and
resprayed his seat
the basic idea here is that you should
spend your time doing things that are
the most value to you and one of the
ways you can do this is by outsourcing
your tasks tim mentions hiring a virtual
assistant before i start talking about
these let me tell you that it can be
very difficult to find a quality VA most
of the time they're overseas and in
different time zones some have trouble
communicating in english the time and
energy you save is definitely worth it
these hired hands can do anything from
web research to writing articles to even
remembering birthdays and automating
Amazon purchases if you trust them
enough the idea here is outsourcing give
low return or repetitive tasks to
someone else for a price evan has a team
and he can do this great he can put
notes together set up the video details
and have his team worry about the rest
of the details this is how he's able to
create so much content so quickly this
is the whole idea of the 4-hour workweek
to outsource your tasks for a profit
whether that be money or meaning or
adding value to someone's else's life
remember that profit is different for
everyone
profit can be 100 thousand dollars a
year profit can be making an impact on
1,000 people's lives profit could be
spending a month vacation with your
family
lastly I'd like to give you a few tips
about product creation Tim made his
quick buck selling cognitive supplements
he sold them to people and had his team
worry about the details he had the
original idea and took the risk to start
the company so he gained the reward when
it succeeded he suggests pricing a
product between 50 and 200 dollars
simply because most of the people that
are willing to pay that amount won't
complain about the small details once
they buy the product and this is proven
through his research you will also have
to spend less and manufacturing
thousands of products opposed to a few
hundred one of the easiest and best ways
to do this is to create a knowledge
product instead of creating a physical
product you can create a knowledge
product like an e-book or a series of
videos in which you can sell to the user
those that do well either teach the end
user something or entertain the user
they get rid of our first problem to end
boredom there is no recurring fee to
create this kind of product and you can
sell it an unlimited amount of times
evan is doing a great job creating all
of these videos simply because they will
last forever the impact he has on
everyone else's lives who watch these
videos will last forever
can you imagine showing your
grandchildren something that you created
unless there is something like a black
hole or a catastrophic internet failure
everything he creates all the content he
creates online will be available forever
one other thing that Tim suggests is
setting up a fake sales page and
allowing potential customers to click
all the way through the buying process
until they get to a screen that says
sorry we're out of stock and using some
handy web tools you can see how many
people would have bought the product if
it was available now the cool thing
about this trick is that you don't
actually have to have a product yet you
can see who would buy your product if
you made it you can even set it up so
that it'll send them an email after you
make the product or when you
quote-unquote restock I'm so glad Evan
gave me the opportunity to speak and
give value to this awesome community I
hope I added value to your life to the
time you have given me and if you want
more awesome book reviews like this
check out my channel at practical
psychology in the description below if
you've ever hired a VA or outsourced to
any task leave a comment below
describing your experience and thanks
for